[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa este es el
magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
empezamos hablando de nicaragua porque
el embajador ante la oea designado por
daniel ortega arturo mcfields se rebeló
y lo calificó de dictador en una sesión
del consejo permanente y en respuesta
ortega dijo que no tenía nada que ver
con ella y seguimos en el sur del
continente en bolivia donde los casi 12
millones de personas que se identifican
como aymaras denuncian que sus obras
literarias están invisibilizadas por
falta de apoyo del estado les contamos
más desde la paz
y luego vamos a brasil donde un nuevo
asesinato de un joven afro despertó la
ira ciudadana y deja en evidencia el
racismo estructural y endémico que azota
a la nación suramericana
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal en una sorpresiva
intervención el embajador de nicaragua
ante la organización de estados
américanos arturo mcfields rompió filas
con daniel ortega y lo llamó dictador al
comparecer ante el consejo permanente de
la oea el funcionario pidió por la
liberación de los presos políticos y
denunció que en el país centroamericano
no hay libertad de prensa desde managua
el gobierno dijo luego que max jones no
lo representa pese a que fue designado
por el propio ortega apenas en octubre
del año pasado tras sus declaraciones
maxion dijo tener miedo y es que sus
palabras son un claro revés para la
estrategia diplomática de ortega quien
ha mantenido el discurso de que en
nicaragua hubo un intento de golpe de
estado en su contra en las
manifestaciones de 2018 a las que
reprimió con violencia dejando más de
360 muertos según la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos la
cdh que es precisamente el órgano de la
oea encargado de proteger los derechos
humanos veamos más en el informe
preparado por luis muñoz
y va a ser una sesión más de la
organización de estados américanos pero
el embajador de nicaragua ante la oea
arturo mcfields se rebeló contra su
propio gobierno tomó la palabra el día
de hoy en nombre de más de 177 presos
políticos y más de 350 personas que han
perdido la vida en mi país desde el año
2018 denunciar la dictadura de mi país
no es fácil
pero seguir guardando silencio y
defender lo indefendible
es imposible mcfields en el cargo desde
octubre de 2021 tenía que liderar el
proceso para que nicaragua abandonase la
oea salida después de que el organismo
no reconociese el resultado de las
elecciones del pasado mes de noviembre
sin embargo el gobierno reaccionó con un
comunicado asegura que su representante
ante la oea es el embajador en eeuu
francisco camps el hooker el señor
arturo mcfields no nos representa por lo
cual ninguna declaración suya tiene
validez rápidamente tanto la oea como
diplomáticos de otros países de américa
latina' aplaudieron a maxfield también a
anthony blinken secretario de estado de
eeuu hoy el embajador de nicaragua ante
la oea máxima renunció en protesta
denunciando el régimen de ortega murillo
por su historial de opresión y contra
los derechos humanos
felicitamos el coraje de marfil al dar
voz a los millones de compatriotas
nicaragüenses que esperan un retorno a
la democracia
esta semana la ex candidata presidencial
cristiana chamorro fue condenada a 8
años
es una de las al menos 46 figuras
opositoras detenidas en el pasado año
que llevaron a eeuu y la unión europea a
decir que la última elección de daniel
ortega fue ilegítima nos íbamos a
estados unidos para revisar rápidamente
sus noticias de esta semana
el comité judicial del senado interrogó
a la nominada a la corte suprema del
presidente joe biden a qué tan gay brawn
jackson se le vio emocionada hasta las
lágrimas cuando se mencionó por el
momento histórico que su nominación
representa pues si es confirmada sería
la primera magistrada afroamericana e
integraría la minoría de tres
progresistas pues los otros seis
magistrados son conservadores jackson
fue cuestionada sobre temas clave como
el derecho al aborto y el control de
armas y fue criticada por ser
supuestamente laxa en casos de
pornografía infantil y defender a
afganos acusados de terrorismo en el 11
de septiembre
y falleció por un cáncer a sus 84 años
madeleine albright la primera mujer que
lideró la diplomacia de eeuu fue
secretaria de estado entre
1997 y 2001 en el segundo gobierno de
bill clinton o bright se convirtió en un
icono feminista de la cultura papá
y el lugar más feliz del mundo por
cualquier cosa menos eso esta semana ya
que los empleados de disney en florida
protestaron por la que consideran es una
falta de reacción de la compañía al
proyecto de ley que prohíbe discutir
temas el gti q más en las escuelas los
empleados del parque temático pidieron a
disney que deje de financiar las
campañas de los políticos que apoyen la
iniciativa
vámonos al sur del continente a bolivia
que ha sido elegida este año como sede
del instituto iberoamericano de lenguas
indígenas con el objetivo de preservar
las lenguas nativas del país y
revitalizar las ante la amenaza de su
desaparición y es que si bien el aymara
es una lengua con muchos hablantes y
tiene fuerte presencia en la nación sus
artistas aseguran que también necesitan
más apoyo para crecer veamos más en el
informe de nuestra corresponsal en la
paz mery vaca hangwani hacker agitaba
sus úteros arum sharp y gritaba
en sus versos el escritor boliviano
rubén hilar y habla de la pervivencia de
la lengua indígena aymara en el tiempo
su poemario lleva por título una palabra
de 36 letras que es de difícil
pronunciación incluso para algunos
aymaras
así mañana que ese equipo era que estaba
que significa todos debemos estar en
constante comunicación unos con otros
los autores aymara se escriben
literatura y ensayos sobre lingüística
sociología e historia sin embargo sus
obras según hilario están
invisibilizadas por falta de apoyo
estatal hay bastante material producido
no y otras veces no se conoce no se
muestra no se promociona no hay ferias
de libros en aymara por ejemplo más de
1.2 millones de personas se identifican
como aymaras en bolivia con la submarca
miami junto a white to work ar una cata
que puntúa en la ciudad de el alto dos
músicos han logrado éxitos haciendo rap
en esa lengua andina a nosotros nos
llamaban del orgullo también animan un
poco
y ayudar a crecer nuestra cultura
nuestro lenguaje nuestro idioma de todo
además la radio ha sido el medio que ha
ayudado a mantener vivo el idioma maya
fácil marcas canarias que a través
criptas criatura radio sant gabriel
tiene 67 años y se ha convertido en un
emblema de la identidad aymara dentro y
fuera del país porque mucha gente no
olvida su origen su identidad por más
que esté fuera de bolivia si recordad al
contrario de las lenguas nativas que
están en extinción en américa latina el
aymara mantiene su vitalidad pero su
cultura requiere apoyo para mostrarse al
mundo cuya canacar
comunidad danza vanguardia tante vamos a
revisar la imagen de la semana ella es
francia márquez y es la primera mujer
afro en aspirar a la vicepresidencia de
colombia
la activista medioambiental sorprendió
en las urnas por su alta votación en la
consulta de izquierdas para definir la
candidatura presidencial será la fórmula
del aspirante elegido gustavo en
representación de la coalición pacto
histórico colombia es el tercer país del
continente con la mayor población afro y
el primero es brasil vamonos
precisamente para allá para seguir
hablando de la población afro una vez
más el racismo endémico y estructural
quedó en evidencia en brasil que sigue
conmocionado por la muerte de moix cava
gabe de 24 años y de origen congolés que
fue salvajemente asesinado en río de
janeiro tras reclamar a su jefe el pago
de sus salarios atrasados un crimen
violento que deja en evidencia también
la xenofobia veamos más en el reportaje
de perín one y luís raleigh
madureira cuna de la cultura negra en
río de janeiro un barrio popular en el
corazón de la zona norte tal como gran
parte de la comunidad congolesa es aquí
donde vivía muy es cava gamba 24 años a
finales de enero el joven fue
brutalmente asesinado golpeado por tres
hombres tras una pelea frente a la
tienda de playa en la que trabajaba
desde aquel día daniel el primo de moix
lucha con su familia para obtener
justicia tras recibir amenazas ahora
viven encerrados
ya no puedo hacer nada me da miedo lo
que pueda suceder me afuera
yo siento que si salgo puedo ser
asesinado como mi hermano digo lo mismo
y bueno huyó de la guerra civil en congo
y creía sentirse segura en brasil donde
el 56 por ciento de la población es
afrodescendiente pero sucedió lo
contrario según el más reciente mapa de
las violencias en el 2019 en brasil el
77 por ciento de las víctimas de
homicidios eran negras del mortal en
señal de protesta ese día en la playa de
vara de yuca barrio privilegiado de río
de janeiro miles de manifestantes se
reunieron en el lugar del crimen frente
a la tienda en la que muestra bajaba
el asunto muy mediatizado reunió a mucha
más gente de la que la familia de moggi
se esperaba
no
[Música]
hoy estamos reunidos porque aquellos que
asesinaron a moix nos asesinan todos los
días de distintas formas el racismo a la
brasilera la xenofobia nacional volvía
los fascistas en el poder vamos a tumbar
los estamos aquí para gritar las vidas
negras cuentan y paren de matarnos
crímenes denunciados con frecuencia aquí
en el consejo de la judicatura de río
rodrigo montego defiende a la familia de
moix y muchos otros
el estado prioriza algunos crímenes los
que son cometidos contra personas
blancas son tratados con mucha seriedad
si son cometidos contra personas negras
las investigaciones son mucho más lentas
casi todos los jueces de brasil son
blancos y provienen casi todos de
familias ricas analizando un asunto
sienten más empatía por quien se les
parece que por una persona que es
diferente
injusticias que se repiten casi al mismo
tiempo otro crimen racista enluta rió
mientras regresaba a casa durval teófilo
padre de familia de 38 años fue
asesinado con tres disparos por su
vecino un militar blanco quien dice
haber creído que era un ladrón
un homicidio calificado inicialmente
como involuntario una decisión que
generó escándalo antes de que el
carácter intencional haya sido agregado
a los cargos
una historia muy común en un país en el
que el racismo estructural sigue dejando
víctimas tan solo en río en estos
últimos 35 años menos de 300 procesos
por injuria y crimen racista se han
traducido en condenas
y me despido en argentina con la
advertencia que tuvo que hacer el
presidente alberto fernández en medio de
la ruptura dentro de su gobierno
especialmente con su vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner el
mandatario tuvo que salir a decir que él
es el presidente y pidió unidad en medio
de la división generada por las
diferencias entre el pacto alcanzado
entre la casa rosada y el fondo
monetario internacional- para
refinanciar la deuda contraída por el
gobierno de mauricio macri reiteró que
él no es títere de nadie en referencia a
su mentora
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
giovanni agudelo envíenme sus
comentarios a las redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas y
para más información de nuestro
continente sigan viendo france24 hay
france24 puntocom
[Música]